[Música]
o sol que usa mais o vídeo eo facebook
nas contas de uma cobra que em 204
colhida em algum obstáculo ela muda de
direção ainda desconhecidas e risco zero
e forem crianças não faz um produto
porque é mais gordo e também vai ser
muito mais divertido para vozes mas por
fazer dois círculos com conceitos e
outro com quatro tentos de raio de forma
que a distância entre o centro seja de 7
centímetros por 40 exato
depois marca em duas linhas em paralelo
de forma que vocês possam dobrar na
borda da mesma coloca em cola no centro
e como em todas com mais ou menos esta
aparência de forma que quando tudo
estiver do lado os ânimos internos sejam
do 180graus
são três círculos com 25 tentos de raio
e helicópteros dando uma tesoura
utilizada uma tampa com dentro do
segmento inferior e forem ela ao mãe
por isso usei uma furadeira mas vocês
não tiverem podem usar uma faca afiada e
coloque a ponta contra o centro da tampa
e vão mudando até que o buraco fica do
tamanho desejado cola em tampa no centro
de um círculo
depois coloque outro círculo por cima de
forma que os três furos fiquem todos
centralizados ser esterilizados usando
exato depois corta el mayo fizerem podem
custar mais uma vez a maio mas estou
autorizado um pequeno cuidados para
criar um círculo com o mesmo diâmetro
deste tipo de cartão
eu corto e com muito cuidado para ficar
bem feito e depois de terem a camada da
super fica na parte interna do lado você
tem que ficar quase beijo gênero depois
tem que pular em cima da polia muito
importante que um furo da parte metálica
que fica em cima do furo da folia deste
ano encontra mesmo é pra ficar tudo bem
liso um parafuso e mar bola passar pelo
meio da folia depois passem por isso foi
o que eu fiz ao lado do centro é mais ou
menos de dois centímetros para fora do
centro
lá tem filmar gola em uma porta para
aprender tudo
moro em dois cliques ou então dois
pedaços de arame com a sua aparência e
cola é um pedaço de um lado e outro do
lado oposto da folia que a linha formada
entre os dois clipes tem que passar pelo
centro da polia usar esta tampa aqui
como suporte para o motor que vou usar
do seguida da queima gordura suficiente
para ultrapassar
depois fez uma abertura letral de mais
ou menos 90 graus que vai permitir
contactar a folia do motor canon
a polícia garante que nós fizemos
anteriormente para fazer a minha própria
ansiedade e dois círculos com um centro
de raio e mais dois títulos com 1,3
centímetro de raiva
agora não sei fazer o cerco estão perto
um dos outros porque se a mãe complicado
executar e que eu fiz um tributo ao mec
mas você tem que fazer um big mac porque
fica muito melhor ok foram só duas
camadas mais não três
faça um furo no centro 31 01 furadeira
mas vocês podem tentar usar um político
enfiado e vão conseguir fazer também
agora foi um tubo de cola no furo que
vocês fizeram anteriormente e coloca o
eixo do motor que vocês tiverem lá está
a usar um motor com caixa de produção ou
seja é um cantor que gira bem devagar e
tem alguma força
agora vou encaixar o motor na tampa e
como vocês podem ver encaixa muito bem
para ficar bem fixa é só por um pouco
escola nesta parte superior
agora eu coloquei o elástico nas duas
corridas mas vocês não conseguem ver
aqui porque era um caso difícil
demonstrar isso
e é só você descolar em forma que um
laço e ficado entre as duas polícias
para fazer um sensor necessidade de
cortar 5 centímetros de um palito
isolado
vocês não tiveram que comprar uma caixa
inteira de políticos podem simplesmente
comer um gelado e ficar com o conflito
ou então podem colar duas camadas cartão
e dar uma forma igual e isso sobre um
furto numa das extremidades do povo
então deputado capitão que você estiver
em utilizar e foi um cola no outro lado
não tem futuro
eu já fiz um sensor não mostrei como eu
fiz isto porque ficava sem um caso
difícil de vocês olharem uma vez que eu
ganhava muito esta peça mas olhando
pelas imagens vocês conseguem facilmente
chegar a mesma coisa que eu fiz aqui
agora vou usar uma tampa de um garrafão
do cinquentão 6 litros d'água e vou
colar motora do plástico já tinha deste
motor mas se vocês não tiverem o clube é
podem simplesmente colocar bastante cola
no centro da tampa
depois foi o eixo do motor lá no centro
e espero até que a escola sec comentou
na quarta 30 e cobra onde fica
atualmente a boca coloque um parafuso um
fio elétrico uma argola e uma porta para
aprender
agora não dá pra entender muito mas já
vou virar está contrário e vocês já vão
perceber melhor vocês vamos fazer o
mesmo assim não se preocupam em que mais
para frente vamos ter aí está outra vez
agora estão cortadas em pedaços de cola
quente com mais ou menos dois
centímetros de comprimento e vou colocar
isso nos motores para fazer a aliança
entre
a cobra eo chão para por aí sempre usar
esta coisa que não sei como é que chama
e acho que no partido e utilizando uma
chave de fendas
mas se vocês não tiverem isto podem
fazer isso usando um prego
agora vou colocar os motores um de cada
lado e vejo aquela linha passa pelo meio
do círculo grande é muito importante e
agora estou a ver como eu de fornecer
desviando forma que os motores levem
cobra para frente não para trás
assim só resta para talvez seja um pouco
confuso e por alguns de vocês
basicamente você tem que colocar os
carros da mesma cor que eu coloco no
final junto em tudo
nós vamos ver os convênios e os projetos
completos e depois ligam a bateria foi
para vocês podem dizer os comentários e
eu posso fazer um esquema de postar no
facebook ou seja o esquema do circuito
elétrico conectado a um clipe ao lado
positivo do motor lateral e fez a mesma
coisa é para o outro lado ou seja outro
clube para o outro notório estão
conectar o rio verde por exemplo está
por baixo do motor é um dos pólos equipe
colorada não importa muito e isto
conectar um fio esta horário aqui de um
sensor e outra extremidade você está em
conectar ao lado positivo da bateria
quando vocês têm por uma antena o
circuito país daí a rotina começa a
gerar para um dos lados dessa forma
cobra de vias e os obstáculos na parte
baixa cantora bastante simples você está
em conectar todos os carros vistos por
um lado e todos os carros pretos para o
outro lado
vamos dar três voltas mas vocês quiserem
podem juntar duas pilhas aa insere e vão
ter três votos e vai funcionar também
como vocês podem ver que já funciona
muito bem e agora vou dar um aspecto de
cobra mas se vocês quiserem podem fazer
isto pode ser um novato a outro bicho
qualquer base aqui do projeto era mesmo
isso estou querendo ensinar os esta
coisa de variar ou alternar eletricidade
entre dois motores e para fazer os anéis
da cobra é só fazer vários círculos e
nalgumas delas e terei um quadrado no
maio
depois coloquei essas bolinhas aqui que
encontrei nas coisas da minha mãe
acho que o tempo de bijuterias que cinco
clubes
aproveitei para estar aqui é muito mais
útil
minha mãe da entidade fica muito e hoje
e amanhã filhos bilheterias como estado
não pode dizer que usei para outras
coisas que não via tantos depois das
aulas todas usando parafusos e em dia
que é o circo alternadamente ou seja que
elas têm aquela bolinha que ajuda a
movimentar alternadamente
mas se vocês não tiverem aquelas
bolinhas podem simplesmente fazer com o
tempo a portuguesa juntando os detentos
fazem forno maio e metem anp aquela
coisa de madeira e para dar um pouco do
meu colocar estes copos plásticos
espero que vocês tenham gostado desse
projeto aqui se tiver mais de três mil
likes então eu pude moura cobra muito
mais realista que vocês foram
controlados algum comando efe o então o
comando mais simples começa aqui por
cadu
além de controlarem a cobra não foi a
também fazer além de esperar alguma
coisa por exemplo elástico então balas
de papel passado fez milagre então você
diga nos comentários querem que seja
controlado por um documento ou então por
isso aqui é isso muito bem assistido até
a próxima